c'était une première audience
effectivement très éprouvante céline rue
bay s'est présenté devant la cour
d'assises les traits tirés les yeux
rougis par les larmes
mais elle s'est exprimée clairement elle
raconte son parcours
un premier enfant né en 2007 d'une
première union qui avait duré un an
mais au moment de l'annoncé de la
grossesse le papa décide de se séparer
de la maman et puis en 2012
deux jumeaux issus d'une autre relation
là encore le couple se sépare avant la
naissance des bébés et puis vient
l'évocation de ce fameux 1er novembre
ce jour là céline ribes et se lève en se
disant que c'est le dernier jour de sa
vie mais elle ne veut pas laisser ses
enfants seuls derrière elle moi je pense
que le passage à l'acte s'explique par
le fait que l'on à une personne qui
était dans une pré cités pression est
intense extrêmement intense pas pas la
dépression dont on parle dans le langage
commun la dépression au robot a été
primé un petit coup de pied aux fesses
et puis ça va repartir
bon là c'est la dépression c'est
psychiatrique avec que des mois
d'euphorie avec des moments on tombe
dans le trou et personne ne voit rien
venir et pumila cette femme se sent seul
et puis un jour se sont tellement seule
qu'elle apprend d'autre solution que de
dire je m'en vais je m'en vais et ben
non je m'en vais pas parce que mes
enfants me restait donc je voudrais que
mes enfants il y avait eu une première
alerte quatre mois plus tôt céline rue
bay avait été hospitalisé d'office en
hôpital psychiatrique en pleine de
bouffées délirantes elle avait laissé
deux de ses trois enfants seul dans son
appartement alors qu'elles s'étaient
rendus à une fête en filigrane on évoque
également la conversion de l'accusé à un
islam radical pendant quelques années
une fois avec laquelle elle a
complètement rompu aujourd'hui et
qu'elle met sur le compte d'un malaise
existentiel d'un manque de repères